In the example, we're just talking about with the marvel comic book characters,
the strength of the link between some character i and some character j
was the number of comic books they appeared in together.
Now, this is an actually very useful metric for real life social networks.
I have not appeared in any comic books with anyone.
I have one friend who actually has appeared in a comic book,
research her by the name of Micheal Bowling at the University of Alberta,
actually had a comic book character made about himself, which is pretty awesome.
But I didn't appear in that comic book with him, so that's not a very good metric.
We won't really need to be studying weighted social networks just for comic book characters,
but there's lots of natural measures of the strength of a connection
between a person i and a person j.
You could imagine saying they're more stronger connected
as a function of how often they email each other,
or maybe how many years they have known each other,
the frequency at which they meet in a given week,
how often they rate each others post on some kind of social networking site,
or maybe the number of news articles both have read
and you can imagine ask more examples like this.
This notion of having a weight in a social networking is actually a pretty
important and relevant concept.
We had talked about shortest paths in a graph,
but now let's extend this notion to the shortest weighted path in our graph.
Here, in this example now, we're going to look at a high weight meaning a weak connection
and a low weight meaning a strong connection.
You can think of the weights as almost as being a kind of cost
and we're looking for basically cheap roots from one person and a network to another.
The example of this sort of thing might be that we want to
send a message from one person to another in a social network
minimizing, say a social awkwardness.
For example, my son is really interested in American history
and my Dean is an expert in American history,
and he wanted to ask the Dean a question, but that's kind of awkward.
They actually don't know each other directly.
They accept that they do know each other directly at see.
Random young man don't generally contact Deans of big school of arts and sciences.
There's a sort of a high social awkwardness for that,
but I was able to help get a message for my son to the Dean
because I have very low social awkwardness with my son
and I have fairly low social awkwardness with the Dean.
The path of sending a message basically recommendation
for a book to read about American history, traveled much more easily through me to the Dean
than it would have to the Dean directly, and I should note that my son also has curly hair.